So when a bicycle kick is scored, it's usually one of the most amazing sights in football.
And because of the complexity of the technique,...
...if it does hit the back of the net, it's usually shown all over the world.
And the circumstance where a bicycle kick might occur...
...is when a player's running into the box anticipating a cross...
...and the ball actually ends up going high and behind the player,...
...so they have to turn around with their back to goal and it's too high for them to head...
...or too high for them to take down on their chest and volley,...
...so they have to hit it first time out of the air.
So they drive up into the air, their foot comes up and they're kicking it over their head...
...and usually it surprises the goalkeeper.